insgesamt muss man nach diesen
Wochenende nach diesen sehr guten
afd-wochenende aber natürlich gestrigen
Landtagswahlen Niedersachsen sagen dass
wir eine Trendwende eingeläutet haben
dass wir uns natürlich als allererstes
bei unseren Wählerinnen und Wählern
bedanken möchten die uns so zahlreich
unterstützt haben gewählt haben
natürlich auch den ganzen Wahlhelfern
den Kandidaten die in hervorragenden
Wahlkampf geleistet haben auch die
Bundespartei die uns aus allen
Bundesländern reichlich Unterstützung
gegeben hat aus den Landesverbänden aus
dem
bundeslandeskreisverbänden auch
teilweise die und nach Niedersachsen
gereist sind unterstützt haben auch ich
möchte mich persönlich im Namen des
gesamten Bundesvorstandes bei Herrn
martinschewski Drewes bedanken hat als
Spitzenkandidat wirklich eine super
Arbeit geleistet hat sich von Anfang an
engagiert eingebracht hatte ein
ambitioniertes Wahlziel mit zwölf
Prozent herausgegeben und hat sich daran
abgearbeitet und hat sich hochgearbeitet
und am Ende sind 10,9% geworden ein
sensationelles Ergebnis mit hier sehr
zufrieden sind die Mandate haben sich in
Niedersachsen damit auch verdoppelt
damit wird auch so auch eine starke
Opposition in den Landtag einziehen zu
den Themen
muss ich sagen und möchte ich auch
einiges sagen vor allem haben natürlich
auch bundespolitische Themen eine Rolle
gespielt zu den
landespolitischens gedreht ist dann
gleich noch was sagen wir haben eben
Alleinstellungsmerkmale bei dieser
Landtagswahl durchaus gehabt ist schon
den Bürger natürlich die Hauptprobleme
was Preissteigerung angeht was Inflation
angehen was Energiesicherheit angeht und
da haben wir als Bundespartei auf die
richtigen Themen gesetzt aber auch auf
die richtige Lösung wir haben die
Ursachen klar benannt die wir aktuell in
diesem Land haben dass der
Wirtschaftskrieg der Bundesregierung der
Deutschland und die Bürger und die
Mittelstand hier in den Abgrund führt
das haben wir immer benannt und das ist
die Ursache die hier in diesem Land dazu
geführt hat dass die Bürger uns vertraut
haben dass die Bürger vor allem auch die
vielen Wähler aus FDP und CDU gerade die
FDP was mich besonders gefreut hat die
ehemalige mit und
mittelstands- und handwerkspartei die
dadurch abgestraft wird weil sie eben
für ihre Wähler keine Politik mehr
betreibt das haben wir übernommen das
werden wir auch im Landtag und natürlich
auch im Bundestag weiter fortsetzen dass
wir das natürlich weiter auch
vorantreiben und auch für diese wäre
natürlich Politik machen das ist die
Herausforderung
insgesamt haben wir auch gesehen dass
wir jetzt natürlich diese Wähler die wir
gewonnen haben eben nicht nur aus dem
Protestlager gewonnen haben sondern dass
wir mit Überzeugung aus FDP und
CDU-Wähler zu uns rübergezogen haben
dass wir die natürlich erstammwähler
gewinnen wollen das ist das Ziel
die nächsten Jahre das muss auch die
Aufgabe der Landtagsfraktion sein und
wie gesagt ich denke damit haben wir ein
gutes Fundament geschaffen die
Trendwende auch im Westen ist damit
eingeläutet unser Ziel mein Ziel war
immer dass wir über 10% auch im Westen
stark kommen und unser Ergebnis festigen
das ist jetzt in Niedersachsen erreicht
und das wird auch uns Auftrieb geben für
die Wahlkämpfen für die nächstes Jahr in
einigen Bundesländern stattfinden das
von meiner Seite erstmal vielen Dank
vielen Dank lieber Tino ja erstmal auch
ohne den ich mich ganz herzlich bedanken
bei allen Wählern in Niedersachsen die
die AFD so stark gemacht haben ganz
herzlichen Dank an die Bundesspitze an
alle Landesverbände und an jeglichen
Kreisverbänden insgesamt Deutschland die
uns geholfen und unterstützt haben mein
herzliches Dank ohne diese Hilfe wäre
dieser Erfolg nicht möglich gewesen
ja dieses Wahlergebnis bin ja auch viel
gefragt worden mit Protest ist es eben
keine Protestwahl da wo ich
Direktkandidat war Gifhorn Nord ist der
einzige Wahlkreis in Niedersachsen wo
mehr Wähler zur Wahl ohne gegangen sind
als weniger die AFD steht eben so wie es
auch jetzt unser Programm ist wie am
Samstag auch demonstriert worden ist auf
der Seite der normalen Menschen wir
machen Politik für unsere Bürger hier
vor Ort das habe ich immer gesagt und so
wird es auch die neue Landtagsfraktion
tun und um auch das ihr gleich vorweg zu
nehmen weil ich werde ja immer gefragt
können sie garantieren dass die Fraktion
nicht verbricht
ich bin seit Jahren in leitender
Position tätig seit sechs Jahren bin ich
Fraktionsvorsitzender am Kreistag oder
Stadtrat in Gifhorn ich weiß wie man
Menschen zusammenführt die weiß wie man
Erfolg hat deswegen ist auch dieses
Wahlergebnis zustande kommt ja und wir
unterscheiden uns ganz klar von ganz
vielen
Funktionsträgern der Grünen oder der SPD
ich bin doppelter Facharzt ich habe
keinen getürkten oder selbst moderierten
Lebenslauf den ich jede Woche ändere das
habe ich nicht nötig und ich als Arzt
lebe von einer einzigen Währung und so
ist es als Politiker auch vom Vertrauen
und unsere Themen die wir einbringen
wollen und so werde ich auch unter
meiner Führung die Fraktion leiten sind
Sachthemen das heißt ganz konkret in
Niedersachsen
Förderschule lernen erhalten die nicht
mehr vermittelbaren und ungerechten
Straßenausbaubeiträge abschaffen
Bürokratieabbau wirklich ernst nehmen
datenschutzgrundverordnung braucht
keiner viele Vereine ächzen darunter
heißt bitte sofort abschaffen auch ganz
klar wo sie mich ja so sehen als Arzt
maskenpflicht gibt es nur noch in
Deutschland und bitte erklären Sie mir
warum im Oktoberfest keine maskenpflicht
ist aber noch in dem Nahverkehr wenn die
Schüler damit zur Schule fahren ich kann
sie nicht erklären Schule heißt
schlechteste Lehrerversorgung unter SPD
seit 19 Jahren hier ganz konkrete
Vorschläge heißt
IT-Administratoren auf Landesebene für
jede Schule damit die Lehrer entlastet
werden schulassistenten damit die Lehrer
entlastet werden weil es gibt nicht
genug Lehrer mehr Lehrer fordern alle
nur es sind endlich da also
afd-politik steht für tatsächlich
praktische Politik die sofort umsetzbar
ist das heißt auch ein Thema was Bundes
aber auch Landesebene ist eine Reform
des öffentlichen Rundfunks NDR so wie
ich es auch gesagt habe dass dort eben
keine Politik keine Klima der Angst
herrscht ich spreche mit jedem
wenn ich sage ich spreche mit jedem
meine ich das so und ich weiß auch was
vertraulichkeit ist das heißt meine
Bürotür steht für jeden offen und
worüber gesprochen wird dass es halt
vertraulich das ist mein Erfolgsrezept
und so wäre ich das auch in der
Landtagsfraktion fortführen
ich freue mich tatsächlich und wir haben
das darf ich Ihnen versichern das kann
ich Ihnen sagen weil ich Montags seit
ungefähr elf Monaten je fast jeden
Montag auf der Straße bin heute werde
ich es nicht schaffen ich habe das auch
gesagt also ganz lieben Gruß an alle
Spaziergänger in Gifhorn wir die die
dort mitlaufen ist der Querschnitt der
Bevölkerung und wir sind eben
tatsächlich angekommen im Westen das
kann ich Ihnen auch sagen seit gestern
haben wir über 40 neue Mitgliedsanträge
in Niedersachsen wir werden wachsen wir
werden stark werden unsere Zeit beginnt
erst hier im Westen vielen dank
grupala
denen die Ergebnisse in Niedersachsen
inwieweit hätten sie sich die selbst ans
also als allererstes sind wir als Partei
angetreten natürlich hatten wir auch in
Niedersachsen einen Spitzenkandidaten
hat ich habe es ja eingangs erwähnt auch
die denke die Geschlossenheit des
gesamten Bundesvorstandes und es ist
nicht die Hauptaufgabe oder die
alleinige der alleinige Erfolg von Kino
entgegenteil wir treten als Team auf wir
sind immer als Team aufgedreht mit Alice
Weidel und Tino propala zusammen wir
haben unsere Politik abgestimmt unsere
Themen abgestimmt und ich denke das
erkennt der Wähler man traut uns
wesentlich mehr
auch Fachkompetenz zu auch das zeigen im
aktuellen in der aktuellen Auswertung
schon die die Umfragen bzw die
nachwahlbefragung dass der Wähler sich
hauptsächlich auch programmatisch bei
uns wiederfindet also das nehmen wir als
Erfolg war und das ist eine natürlich
eine Teamarbeit des Landesverbandes
genauso gewesen des Bundesverbandes also
von daher hat das ist dieser Erfolg nie
bei einer einzelnen Person zu sehen im
Gegenteil also hier haben wirklich viele
daran mitgewirkt und auch viele Menschen
im Hintergrund
und allein unsere Familien die uns
unterstützen haben mit einem
riesenanteil auch das möchte ich mal
betonen bei solchen Wahlkämpfen es wird
ja manchez gedreht ist genauso
bestätigen vor fünf Monaten der
Bundespressekonferenz der war auch eine
Wahl in einem schönen norddeutschen
Bundesland und sie mussten sich anhören
dass sie
dauern verlieren und dass der Westen
eigentlich schon verloren ist ist jetzt
wieder alles gut im Westen geht das so
schnell ich meine damals war auch schon
Krieg
ja sie haben es ja eigentlich selbst
schon beantwortet wie schnell das gehen
kann durch Politik so schnell
ja so schnell geht es jetzt erstmal
nicht in die andere Richtung weil wir ja
die richtigen Themen die richtigen die
richtigen Punkte angesprochen ich habe
es ja schon eingangs gesagt wir sind die
einzige Partei die die Interessen
Deutschland vertreten ist merken
mittlerweile vor allem immer mehr
Menschen die arbeiten gehen die
bearbeitende Bevölkerung wählt uns auch
das zeigt dir die Wahl Nachlese
Mittelständler
Handwerker und das ist genau das
klientierte die Liebe Politik machen die
sie erkennen auch dass wir eine gewisse
Fachkompetenz mittlerweile vorweisen
können und das werden wir jetzt auch
ausbauen auch im Westen diese Trendwende
ich habe es ja eingangs gesagt ist mit
Niedersachsen passiert und wir werden
natürlich auch nächstes Jahr den
Landtagswahlen in Hessen in Bayern auch
in Berlin wird sich ja noch meine
Landtagswahl geben
also das wäre natürlich auch unsere
Steckenpferde werden dass wir diese
Wahlen weit über zweistellig gewinnen
wollen bzw erfolgreich gestalten wollen
gerade noch gesagt hat sind die nächsten
Landtagswahlen ziemlich genau einem Jahr
die nächsten wichtigen Landtagswahlen in
Hessen und Bayern da haben die
ampelparteien und die ebenfalls gezauste
Union Glück dass jetzt eine
bevorstehenden harten Winter keine
Landtagswahlen sind und man 12 Monate
Zeit hat aus diesem Wahlergebnis in
Niedersachsen die Lehren zu ziehen auch
aus dem Ergebnis für die AFD der
Vollständigkeit halber im Mai wird schon
im kleinsten Bundesland in Bremen
gewählt also im Winter wie gesagt keine
Landtagswahl auch keine anderen Wahlen
von Bedeutung ja das zunächst mal als
Resümee hier aus Berlin und jetzt zurück
zu Marlon amoiyal